uh first of all how are you doing how's
it going
i'm well i'm well how are you really
great i saw uh you posted on insta
you were signing like a hundred
different album covers how's your arm
how's your hand no no it's um it's fine
it's you know i take breaks
when you do get to sort of
this point where this record seems like
it has been
so long in the making for
fans what are you feeling right now i
mean stupid psycho came out two years
ago
um yeah we started working on the album
probably a year and a half ago so in
reality
it's not that long um it feels like a
long time maybe because the
last two years maybe i don't know they
went by fast for me but
um i started working on heaven and hell
about a year and a half ago
yeah and what did you want to say on
this um really just about the
roller coaster and emotions we deal with
in life and like the
ups and downs and the it's not
necessarily a religious thing it's more
so
like heaven and hell like the the
emotions we feel every day like having
an
angel or a devil on our shoulder telling
us to do something good or bad it's like
all the mixed emotions we feel in our
lives and careers and relationships so
it's just that kind of duality so
do you grab inspiration from what you
see or do you grab the majority of your
inspiration from what you've felt
what i've felt mostly um like
what i've seen is similar to a lot of
people
feel mixed emotions all the time we're
not just one
thing right uh and what have you felt
what were you feeling going through this
process because oftentimes
you know i've interviewed i can't even
tell you how many
you know young pop stars where
the best art usually comes out of the
worst places that you've been
and which is which is such a which is
such a terrible reality
um but so is that what it was like for
you i mean
growing up i really stem from like a
song like who's laughing now
growing up i had a lot of people tell me
no in the industry that i'm never gonna
make it
and and it really felt almost impossible
so for me
that song is kind of like looking back
and saying hey who's laughing now
like you were wrong and it's it's great
and also in the video it shows
you know i wrote the treatment
specifically for my past
because you see the music coming out of
my veins but i'm locked in the psych
ward
but that's how i felt like i felt like i
did have music coming out of my veins
and
and i did feel like people were trying
to stop me and i
i mean it was so hard to get out of that
but i am a strong
strong woman and i grew up with strong
females around me so i did not stop
so are you are you at the point now
where because it's interesting with
the the success that you've had with
sweep at psycho in kings and queens
are you at the point now of where dreams
are coming true and are you starting to
build new dreams
um you know i still have a lot of goals
left in this dream
um i i do believe in like achieving all
your goals
and and you know it's all possible um
we can do a lot of things as humans and
our voices can be heard all around the
world
and i truly believe that you know if you
just focus on one thing you can
accomplish it and you know that's what
i'm doing
being here right now with you know a
couple of days away from you know a
debut album with the success that you've
had though
this had to have been something you
would lie in bed years ago thinking
about
this this time frame of where you're
about to unleash the vision onto the
world and to your fans
and i want to know how the reality
matches up with what you sort of
lied in bed thinking about i mean yeah
i it does feel amazing although we are
in a global pandemic
we are which is which is pretty crazy i
would have never i mean we would have
never
ever guessed that um there's no way you
could guess that but
um i i feel grateful for all the support
and love i'm getting
even in a pandemic so that's that
already is
i'm feeling super thankful and i feel
like people are listening to music more
in their homes
now it's weird i feel like everyone's
taking me time you know
and and maybe that's a good thing for
music in a way
i know a lot of a lot of young artists
don't like the comparisons which is
understandable
but people started comparing you to gaga
very early on but i'm wondering what
that was like for you whether there was
some sort of relief
that the individual that they were
comparing you to wasn't somebody that
you actually
didn't like imagine imagine yeah no
she's amazing
it's funny because we're probably the
only two blonde pop stars
in the pop world and that's probably why
they are comparing us and um we both
make anthemic music so it's like
it's really interesting how they you
know people in general like to put
people in like certain boxes
like um that because they don't do that
to men
and uh with this with this record when
you sort of look at the idea of
heaven and hell and you know it all
makes sense to you and then it makes
sense on the record but during this
process was there anybody in your life
family or friends
when you would sort of kind of describe
what your philosophy was
whether they wondered if you were okay
um no because my family is
very open they're albanian so they're
like you know they'll tell me when
you know i'm eating too much bread
they'll grab my belly and be like what
are you doing
like to joke around you know and so i
know they're never meaning anything in a
negative way and so they also
know that with me like but you know they
also know when something's actually
wrong
um so they comfort me and they're really
realistic people
yeah so it criticized me especially
because a lot of people ask me how i
handle like the haters online and it's
like
trolls um you know if you want to call
them that but
um i grew up with um a lot of people
telling me
you know you know keeping me grounded do
you read the comments
yeah why why why
it's there you know sometimes you know
not all the time not like i'm not
everyday looking at comments but when i
when i have a second i like to just look
around and read around and i
sometimes land on comments does it but
you know you know what that's
like i mean you know one one thing can
ruin a weekend do you
sort of limit the times that you do
dip into the comment section like you
don't do it right before you're about to
have family time
or watch a comedy or something i'm very
spontaneous so if i do it
it's random it could be like super
random i think it's more so
just about if i'm online looking it
comes i don't know i'm not the type of
person where i'm like scheduling things
if it happens it happens but i have to
say some of the comments are pretty
funny and i laugh at them
because you know the haters are really
the ones
who need the most help right
i gotta see this so you're in being in
the pop world there's been
decades of world-class pop stars
that have been noticed and
oftentimes recognized by
the sort of choice of individual haircut
or style they have chosen to have at the
time
you have this and it's amazing and it
works for you and it is totally you
but are you now in the place of where
you're like god i can't change
this now no i'm not thinking that
actually i'm thinking i really love it
and i feel like i mean do people want me
to change it because i actually really
love it and it feels like me
and it's funny when i was playing the
characters in who's now and some other
music videos
i had the same length and i did not feel
like myself
you didn't no this feels like you now it
feels like me now which is so weird and
the fans started calling it the max cut
i find it just interesting because it's
like it's so me now i haven't messed
with girls
have you seen a fan online that has the
same cut yet
you know um some fans started cutting
their hair like this which hey
to each their own um this haircut is
really just about starting your own
trend
so yep you know i don't like following
what's
cool trendy i don't even try to make my
music sound cool i just wanted to
be emphatic and uplifting i really
believe in like uplifting people so
yeah and that what's your take on pop
because
you want to be you want to be an
individual and you want to be unique and
you got to stand out you have to do all
these things
but the sort of essence for pop is to be
you know popular music which
which you know in its sense doesn't lend
itself a lot of times to being unique
what's your philosophy on you know still
becoming big
in pop while maintaining your
individuality
um i think it's all about again staying
grounded you really have to know who you
are
it took me over 15 years to try and even
break through
the music industry but i you know i saw
nothing else this was my main goal
ever since i was eight years old i've
always wanted to sing singing came
naturally to me like literally the
moment i started
talking i wanted to sing and it was
weird it was like
kind of like a blessing and a curse you
know it's kind of like oh you're this
young you know exactly what you want
when people
kids are playing in the playground i'm
over here like i'm going to california
to be a singer and like i was just this
little girl knowing exactly what i
wanted to do so
it came a little bit with a lot of you
know pressure and struggles because
sure i that's all i was thinking about
in class in math class and science class
i
like i told the teachers hey i want to
be a singer i don't want to be here
and i was always like that oftentimes
people when you because this
when you're young making these decisions
it's not sort of an individual decision
it's in your decision it's oftentimes a
family decision
was there ever conversations of a backup
plan because i think now with the album
and your success we're not going to jinx
anything
was there ever conversations about a
backup plan and for you what was that
backup plan
there was no backup plan actually my dad
always was like you know there should
probably be a backup plan
my dad you know being a dad he was like
you should do this you should do that
like maybe maybe start college and i'm
just like dad
you know that's not gonna happen this is
all i
to do and and at one point you know my
parents were kind of like
i had just 20 a week i was going to
my car was breaking down i was going to
a job
and not being able to go to the studio
session so then i had to quit my job
because i wanted to go to studio
sessions
at a certain time that i was i could and
so i
kind of quit my job and lived off 20 a
week i had really good friends who would
buy me my meals and now i paid them back
well there you go you know it's it's it
was tough at one point i had a lot of
fun
uh congratulations on everything uh you
seem like you're doing very very well uh
the album's great
all the best
you